ideally you want to try to bracket it
and say
success is in the envelope of outcomes
in the beginning there will be there
will be a few people who
who who believe in you or in what you're
doing
and uh but then over time as you make
progress
that the evidence will build and and
more and more people will believe in
what you're doing
we don't love this product but we think
others will love it and you know that's
not really how it works
if you don't love it don't expect others
will either
need motivation watch your top 10 with
believe nation
top
men and 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because chances are you
are the most ambitious person in your
circle but you know you're capable of
more
and you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best
elon musk and my take on his top 10
rules for success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one try
hard you hi you look for innovative
people when you hire them is it
something that that is is pretty easy
easily learnable or is there so many
quality in the people that uh succeed
i think it is learnable i mean step
number one would be try
and it have you tried and if have you
tried hard
and if you haven't tried hard try hard
i think it is learnable um
it's not some mysterious thing it's just
basically just be like
an absolute perfectionist about the
product that you make the service that's
provided
um seek negative feedback from all
quarters uh you know
from customers from from people who
aren't customers like hey okay what can
we make this how do we make this better
and you know i think that's it
it's absolutely learnable and and and
just
if you find yourself spending a lot of
time
in getting presentations and reviewing
spreadsheets
you're blocking up the wrong tree that
that's
that's the effect not the cause so
just get out there on the factory floor
get out there in the stores
talk to customers think about what what
would what would you love to have
oh and you know sometimes i think you
know and i've had this conversation that
it tells a few times
where it's like we're trying to think
okay we don't
make this at times like we don't love
this product but we think others will
love it
you know that's not really how it works
if you don't love it
don't expect others will either rule
number two be persuasive
you think about a company a company is
is a group of people that are organized
to create a product or service
that's a sort of company is so in order
to
um create such a thing you have to
convince others to
join you in in your effort um
and and so they have to be convinced
that
that that it's a sensible thing that uh
it's like that there's at least some
some good some reasonable chance of
success and if if there is success that
the reward will be commensurate with the
effort involved
um and you know
so i think that's getting people to
to believe in what you're doing uh and
in
in you is is important um
so in the beginning there will be
there will be a few people who who who
believe in you
or in what you're doing um and uh
but then over time as you make progress
that the evidence will build
and and more people will believe in what
you're doing
so um i think it's a good idea when
creating a company to
um to create it to have a demonstration
or you know
if it's a product to have like a a a
good markup or
even if software to have good demo wear
or to be able to sketch something so
people can really envision what it's
about
um like that that's a try to get to that
point as soon as possible and then
iterate to make it as as real as
possible as fast as possible
rule number three accept failures if
you're gonna try something innovative
then
then you're in unexplored territories so
that odds that something will go wrong
are pretty high uh if you know it's only
if you
try to do something that is already well
understood that there's
a little little chance of failure but
then it will not be
interesting or innovative so you know
for sure
uncharted territory will result in
failures uh
necessarily otherwise you know trying
hard enough rule number four
read did you surround yourself with
mentors how did you
who did you look to for advice i read a
lot of books and talked to lots of
i didn't have any any one person who was
a mentor but i i always look for
feedback from
from people around me and feedback from
uh
in historical context to you know which
is books basically
also if you want to have more self
belief and more self confidence i've
created a special
free program where every day for the
next 254 days i will send you
an unlisted video to help you boost your
self belief and self confidence the link
to join for free
is in the description below there are
just times when
something is important enough that you
believe it enough that
you you do it in spite of fear before we
were able to get the roadster out
then they'd say well you couldn't
possibly make that car work
when you want to do something new you
have to you have to apply
the the physics approach rule number
five look for competition
and so you want to have a competitive
situation where it's truly competitive
uh where companies aren't gaming the
system
um and and then where the rules are set
correctly um and then you need to be on
the alert for regulatory capture
where the the referees are in fact
captured by the players which is you
know and
the players should not control the
referees rule number six manage your
time well
you're running you're ceo of two
companies you're chairman of solar city
talk about time management how on earth
do you do this
well do you get any sleep uh yeah
sometimes not enough sleep is really
great
uh because because if i find if i don't
get enough sleep then i'm i'm quite
grumpy
um i mean obviously i think most people
are that way
and and also um like i try to sort of
figure out what's the
right amount of sleep because i found i
could have
i could drop below a certain threshold
of sleep and although i'd be awake more
hours and i could sustain it
that would get less done because
my mental acuity would be affected
so i found generally the right number
for me is around six to six and a half
hours
on average per night um that's not too
bad
yeah right and any other tips on average
though
any other tips on just managing to run
two companies simultaneously
i mean do you do you find i mean i know
you're up here monday tuesday is it
all tesla when you're up in silicon
valley and all
spacex wednesday thursday
having a sort of
having a smartphone is incredibly
helpful because that means you can do
email
during interstitial periods like if
you're in a car you're walking in the
bathroom everywhere
you can do email practically when you're
awake
and and so that's really helpful to have
email for spacex and tesla integrated
on my phone um and then
uh and then it's just you have to
apply a lot of hours to actual working
actually working so
the way i generally do it is i'll be uh
working at spacex on monday and then
monday night flight to the bay area uh
spent tuesday and wednesday at the bay
area
then at tesla and then fly back on
wednesday night
spend thursday and friday at spacex
um in in the last several months then i
would fly back here on a saturday
and either spend saturday and sunday at
tesla
or spend saturday at tesla and sunday at
spacex
rule number seven expect success
generally you want to
embark on something it's desirable to
figure out if success
is at least one of the possibilities
right exactly
because for sure failure is one of the
possibilities yes
um but but ideally you want to try to
bracket it and say
success is in the envelope of outcomes
yeah um and i wasn't quite sure if that
was the case
um i mean i think success on an academic
level would have been
quite likely because you can publish
some useless paper and
most papers are pretty useless um you
know we have a few don't take effect
sorry yeah i mean how many php papers
are actually used
by someone ever um i mean no it's a good
point percentage-wise it's not
it's not good and um
so so it could have been one of those
outcomes where
uh you add some leaves to the tree of
knowledge yeah
okay um and and that leaf is nope it's
not possible
right they go seven years a month
um so that what so that was one path
and i was prepared to do that but then
the internet was the error came along
and i was like okay
the internet i'm pretty sure success is
one of the possible outcomes and it
seems like i could either
do a do sort of do a phd and watch the
internet happen
or i could participate and help build it
in some fashion you know
you know like i just couldn't stand the
idea of watching it happen
yeah yeah so that that's uh so i decided
to put things on hold
uh and start an internet company
and that was kind of a we we worked on
internet like publishing software maps
and directions yellow pages kind of
things
rule number eight be innovative first
person when we interview people we
we do ask for some evidence of
exceptional ability
which in most cases includes innovation
this is not said everyone needs to be
innovative it's
but we certainly need those that are
doing advanced engineering to be
innovative
um and ideally everyone is at least some
to some degree
innovative uh so at the interview point
we select for it for people who want
to create new technology
and then the incentive structure is
set up that such that
innovation is rewarded um making
mistakes
along the way does not come with a big
penalty
um and but but failure to
try to innovate at all comes with a big
penalty
you'll be fired okay yeah
all right the carrot and stick that's
the steak if you don't even try
um or or somebody doesn't even try to
innovate or
their innovation um aspirations are are
very
are not not very good
then yeah they will no longer be at the
company
rule number nine look for feedback i
don't have a mentor per se although i
try to
i try to get feedback from as many
people as possible um
and um so i have like friends and i ask
them to you know
what they think of the stat that the
other thing and
um you know especially you know
larry's a good relay page is a good
friend of mine value his advice a lot
and many other good friends and so
so i think it's good to solicit feedback
and particularly negative feedback
actually because you know obviously
people don't love the idea of giving you
negative feedback
um unless unless it's like some you know
on
on blogs they do that and rule number 10
the last one before very special bonus
clip
is have fun we're going to look at some
memes right yes
and say things that are say funny things
about them i think we rate them oh we
rate them okay that's the review and
then
we're reviewing them out of ten of
course okay i mean there's some good
memes here
is this the first one i believe so okay
yeah uh a spoon is just a small bowl on
a stick used to eat from a larger bowl
he's earnestly presenting this
in congress and you can see you can see
how
how how easy it would be to just replace
that text and
add anything you want there it's almost
as though he wasn't saying that
so yeah i rate this uh out of what's the
scale one to ten yeah
is it one to ten oh uh i have five i
guess
yeah six maybe maybe a six yeah is this
it's like a mid-range it's a mid-range
meme yeah i don't think this one's got
legs
also it's kind of tipping into the
political area which is like yeah
who needs it you know if i like get off
my lawn
but just get off my lawn would be
great that would be really good get
i'll bump it up another number because
that's a good so i give it a
six year old man a gas car
and gas car oh
i see so you love you love madagascar
because it's just such a heartwarming
wonderful film
but then gas car you're like what i've
actually never seen this movie
you've never seen no i guess oh no it's
a lot of lemurs i refuse to watch any
movie with the word gaskar in it
that's not bad oh sick but no but i
think i'll make you everything is sick
how do you but but how do you feel about
it is that trippy to like for real
there's a meme of with you in it are you
sort of like what the hell
yeah or have you gotten over that and
you're just like yeah yeah well i mean
this past couple years have been
particularly last year it was meme city
meme city yeah meme city yeah that'd be
nice
a lot of memes okay now this is this is
a a proper quandary
okay okay would you step on stuart
little for 18 billion dollars
i love how poorly photoshopped it's like
it's like it's like they just
they got a gray color and just erased
whatever the hell it is like
just put him in yeah you kid the only
sentient mouse or is it sentient or
sentient
sentient is it sentient
i've always said sentient i've said
sentient
[Laughter]
that's not that's not post at all who is
that guy
that's me oh my god is that a weird
combination
and this is a real this is a is this a
real tweet no okay okay
okay okay okay man dude nothing you
can't believe
it yeah yeah
this is where i'm face smashed with uh
folks alone that's a funny meme that's a
funny one
you could apply it not only to you but
to other celebrities and people
so yeah i i think that's a funny meme
i'd give it because it could be it could
be just like a dumb drawing it could be
anything
it could be so many wonderful things i
give this i say eight
yeah eight it's a solid eight whoa this
is this is so a matter
of me laughing at the idea of me
laughing at me
[Laughter]
jesus christ now i've got a special
bonus clip that i think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and what is your
specific plan of action
for the next week when you just watch a
video and get motivated by it you have a
35
chance of following through but when you
get motivated and then create a specific
plan of action you have a 91 chance of
following through
that's what we do here believe nation we
get motivated but then we do
something about it and when you commit
to other people you increase your
chances even further of following
through
so what was your biggest takeaway from
this video
and then what is your plan of action
around for this week
put it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate
you started out i actually had one of
the very
very first twitter accounts like when it
was like less than 10 000
uh people and and then everyone was
tweeting at me like what kind of latte
they had at starbucks
and i'm like this seems like the
silliest thing ever so i deleted my
twitter account and then
uh someone else took it over and started
tweeting in my name
yeah and then a couple of uh friends of
mine um
well lee and jason calacanis said
they've always said hey you should
really
use twitter to get your message out and
also some
somebody's tweeting in your name and
they're saying crazy things
so i'll say crazy things in my name
did you have to pay them no no they they
they
um i'm not sure who it was but it was
for some reason
i got my account back and um
and then i was just i don't know at some
point it's like just sort of
i just started tweeting for fun really
and my early tweets were quite crazy
uh as i was trying to explain like it
has the arc of insanity
is is short in that it's not very steep
because it started off insane
[Laughter]
[Music]
and so if it's still insane it's you
know hasn't changed that much
um so um
yeah and i don't know i it seems it
seemed kind of fun
to you know as like i said this before
it's like you know some people use their
hair to express myself i use twitter
i love that
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer on this channel i
have a dedicated brand new channel just
for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there